the new studio this is this is the new
space this is a jump this is us this is
who we are now this is this is who we
are we are reminds us now fine tastes
and leisures and no no headphones no
headphones yeah we get to be headphone
free in this space oh okay I was kind of
counting on that for like hair purposes
you didn't picture your makeup on well I
did
I'm just you know I got like a little
there's like a little thing that's like
keeps sticking out on this side I don't
know if you guys can see that and I was
like oh you know what it doesn't matter
because I'm gonna have headphones on and
it's gonna cover that right up so it
doesn't matter I'm gonna go ahead and
say it doesn't matter either way okay
all right your hair looks good just
accept yourself today it's big it's big
I haven't had a haircut in a while okay
but it looks good I like it I like it
was the original
it's a little big today yeah in a good
way thanks man I really like this studio
Megan
um yeah I think you and the team did an
amazing I think you guys you guys did an
amazing job it's beautiful in here I
gotta say I was like yesterday before I
was thinking
um I don't want to do the podcast
anymore oh okay okay let's let's dive
into that what's going on there
um I feel like um like we did it yeah
fun episodes we did it in like halfway
through season three well you know what
it was I tell you what I'll tell you
actually the psychology behind it
because we now have to do it
um and it's it's just the mere fact of
having to do it I always like to do it
we don't have to do it we don't have to
do it but I was like we did we did just
spend a lot of money yeah
Megan's like Megan's like wait a minute
but I think I'll find three other guys
if you guys don't want to be in there
it's fine I do want to do it it's just
that like I was like I go through phase
is right like right now I'd actually
rather be
writing some scripts with you guys or on
set shooting something you know yeah but
only because it had a little break from
it then I'll be doing that and be like I
don't want to be doing this I can tell
you I'm in the middle of production
right now you do not want to be doing it
you know exactly where I want to be this
is where you want to be yeah yeah all
right I'm back I'm back
this episode The Gang sells out I think
right now
is my favorite episode that we've
watched it I'm so glad to hear you say
that I have always at all I've often
cited this episode as one of my uh one
of my favorites it's not one that I hear
fans talking about very often I would
have to agree that this is absolutely
one of our best episodes we've ever done
it is it's just I don't know if you guys
thought about this but like from a
technical standpoint like the structure
of this episode is just really
it's really tight like there's a lot of
story lines going on and then they all
start to kind of weave together and in a
really I don't know really elegant way
I'll give you I'll throw one shout out
to uh Rob Rozelle and Scott martyr when
we so season three was the first season
we started hiring like writers and we
interviewed people and I think we said
look let's come into the room and tell
us some general sort of story ideas that
you'd like and and and things and you
know they they didn't come in with a
storyline about like selling the bar but
they did Pitch that Frank used to be in
a doo-wop group called The Yellow
Jackets
and
I mean that from that moment on their
contribution to the show yeah it was
just fantastic they were a real doo-wop
group that we hired yeah yeah except for
the ultimate for hockey there was one
moment in the entire episode that didn't
work and it was at the very end and do
you remember whether I was watching it
and I remember even at the time
lamenting it and we were trying to get
this guy to do it well okay so hockey
hockey so we wanted hockey to come up to
uh by the way that uh actor Rich
richolow yeah is so good he's fantastic
but he was he was the guy one of the
guys in two guys a girl and a pizza
place oh that's right the other guy was
he's so fantastic some movie star some
yeah some
some guy that likes he's like a soccer
guy now or something
um right right alcohol
Baron he's an alcohol Baron and soccer
guy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that first
scene how we're just arguing amongst
each other and then reveal that the
man's in the room with us is that the
first time we did it or this or we did
it in one other episode no actually
Patel no we we didn't know that that
might have been the first time this is
the first time I remember doing it I
remember when we were coming out with
that bit as we were working on it
thinking that is so
so funny and I don't remember exactly if
it was like we started with the thing of
having the conversation and then we
realized like oh what if the guy's
already in the room and we just turned
and he's there it essentially becomes
that entire storyline where you guys
take him out to the strip bar and then
you yeah become consumed with a very
funny argument about about a bear versus
an otter and the amount of hair and the
power bottom generating all the speed
it's the same joke yeah well and in the
previous scene it's the same joke as
well where and you but you see the
Genesis of how we wind up on those
tangents where it starts about what
we're talking about and then very
quickly becomes about something else in
the scene with Frank yeah when we're
talking to the to them all right to tie
it back in what we wanted hockey to do
yeah was walk right up close to Rich
Rick
rich rich was it rich I thought it was
Rick Rich Ricola I thought he went by
Rick I bet you could go by either if
you're a rich you could be a wreck
anyway to go right up to Ricolo staring
there we go right in the eye and go
queer and then after he calls him queer
to then like have a heart attack and die
yeah pay the price right away yeah and I
remember there were conversations of
like is it kind of sad that this old guy
dies and we were like let's just make
him homophobic like let's just make him
go up there and say something really
offensive and then he dies and then
nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah yeah and and we
just couldn't I never give a [ __ ] about
that we just couldn't get him let the
people die let dogs die I'm like I don't
care to me it's like if it's funny then
yeah no that was always the question was
like is it going to be is it going to be
funny enough or are we gonna We were
still having those kinds of
conversations like yeah yeah I don't I
don't know if this is going to play yeah
the man was not really an actor so he
couldn't he couldn't do it
uh and I remember Matt Jackman who
directed the hell out of that episode
being really frustrated yeah we just
kind of had a workaround where actually
I don't think we had to work around we
just had to cut we just had to cut it
out we had to cut it cut it out and it
works fine it's like he walks up he has
a heart attack but and I do remember who
did that because that wasn't his voice
one of us one of us did the oh yeah oh
yeah yeah one of us did a thing for him
and then at the end of the episode where
we put up the thing he hadn't actually
passed away it's just the character
passing away it kind of looks like yeah
it kind of seems like we're saying that
way yeah well because we've done we've
also done that yeah that's true and the
lifting up of the camera in that was the
Matt shackman thing at the end of the
episode where it goes up to the city of
Philly which we did of course we were in
Philly so we kind of went to White and
clouds but we did shoot in Philly in
that episode though and which is great
is that the the job the job job oh yeah
yeah that wasn't funny yeah that's
Philly where jobs growing jobs uh the
scenes between Maryland together
I love that moment when when Mary when
the waitress says to D
um I thought you told me you weren't
applying here and she says no that was a
lie no that was a lot that scene is
really it's really funny and just the
character looking into another person's
eyes and saying yes that was a lie yeah
you're accepting that and you're moving
on from it yeah yeah well yeah yeah
exactly that's the subtext right it's
like well no that was a lie because
that's what I wanted then at the time
and now I want something different you
know how to do that right yeah yeah you
know I wonder and you have a version of
that later when you say to her why
aren't you this is not attractive to me
aren't you aware of that don't you want
to be addressed don't you want to be
attractive to me yeah yeah it's the
characters like just complete and total
obliviousness in this episode is at its
height like all through the episode like
from beginning to end it's just like
everything I also like the runner of
like whenever anyone gets handed
um you know an application form to fill
out they're just like ah you do it
somebody else do this yeah I think which
is how I feel whenever I'm handed a form
sure I just anybody who wants me foreign
thing which is believable you know that
he was in his do-up group sure uh we
don't have the thing that we had before
of like suddenly we have people running
a sweatshop in our our basement you know
like uh yeah yeah yeah also the music
transitions I remember this Josh Drisco
was cutting it together
and then something wasn't working and
couldn't we were using Sunny music and
we
just stumbled on the sort of 50s rock
and roll kind of uh doo-wop do yeah some
do up transitions in some are just like
uh you know kind of like what you would
imagine like people roller skating up to
a car outside of uh it was the kind of
stuff they would have played at the
oldies at the oldies at the oldies Rock
Cafe yeah what were we going for like
like a hard rock or I think it was a
hollywood-ish type thing but yeah it was
just a Fridays or something and it ties
in really well to Danny's storyline and
the duop group and it all is cohesive
and I don't know that's one that we're
like hey this this works yeah there's
and like I have to say like specifically
I I kind of I do kind of miss playing
some of that stuff that that I get to
play in that episode where I'm a little
more
you know manipulative but like not so
frantic not so like on edge the whole
time yeah so like I like when you say
I'm so sorry for not calling you ever
ever yeah
yeah uh farmer's tan I'm rocking in that
episode
very real it's legit yeah what happened
there is that a golf thing I think so
because I think I just picked up golf
that year yeah because you when did you
start playing golf well I I got like
super into it out here I think when I
turned 30. so I think around season
three but you were you played before you
just you just weren't that into it the
kickballs or my buddies and I uh we
would like sneak onto a course and like
play three holes and then go you know
since we're talking about Charlie and
golf we might as well bring this up
because I find this fascinating about
him this is nothing to to do with the
episode and everything to do with
Charlie
um and because and the podcast because
he's always talking about his memory
being terrible uh no I I will say that
I've discovered over the course of doing
this podcast because it's better than I
thought yeah selective it's selective
yeah right it's like if it if it's
interesting to him and it matters to him
he'll remember it okay so to that very
true to that end Charlie has a very
strange Rain Man like ability to play a
round of golf
with three other people so you could go
out and force them and at the end of
that round of golf you could be having a
drink afterwards and he could tell you
every single shot that every single
person had over the course of the entire
round is that true yeah I I I've watched
him do it it's like a party trick that I
pull out like impress other people I'm
like Bateman watch this that is
fascinating yeah I don't know man I I
can tell you for sure but that's also
because I don't care about golf so when
I play golf I'm just like I can remember
how many beers I had usually but like I
can't remember like any of the shots
because none of them were good I
remember a lot about this particular
episode I think because it was we felt
like it was a good episode and there are
other episodes that I'll watch where I'm
like I can't remember a thing yeah and
it's because the episode doesn't really
grab me or whatever yeah I remember I
remember shooting a lot of these scenes
yeah well I remember where we shot them
what I don't remember is where the
oldies Rock Cafe was that's Long Beach
yeah yeah so so I don't remember that
yeah Long Beach by the aquarium yep near
the Aquarium really do you guys remember
if the uh get a job strap on my job
helmet and get into a job Cannon was
scripted that was not scripted uh well I
think part of it was and then Charlie
turned it into something yeah it was
like it was like go get a job strap or
strap on my job helmet like it was
something it was just oh go get a job
and go get a job or a job I think it was
where jobs grow on trees
and then and then he just realized I
think
my guess is that you probably realized
as you were saying you're like I just
said job the word job like five times I
may as well end it with another job word
yeah the jobbies and I I remember that
was one where we were in the editing
room and I was like that's stupid it
should just be it should just be job
trees and you guys were like oh that's
what it was no it was job trees
and you guys were like not long you're
wrong because I was like okay yeah yeah
wrong look at him It's gotta be jobs it
worked yeah right there were certain
things we established in that episode
like that I had traded all my shares for
parts of Sandwich
uh well there there is one um glaring
mistake yeah and that's the way it says
did you even go to high school yeah did
you go to high school or yeah you know
that's the thing where people don't make
a mistake at the time it wasn't a
mistake at the time it's just that we
made the mistake later well I think we
I'm saying they sat next to each other
and she didn't remember her right d well
D didn't remember the waitress but the
waitress remember you know what when
you're doing a show I would like another
show
is there like people who
are because I guess
some of it is unprecedented right we've
been doing our show longer than most
shows go so when we seven years later
write a joke you know you got to go back
through yeah you need an archives
there's some things you can justify like
for example my character eventually
coming out right you can see some of the
signs of it maybe earlier the idea of
the waitress not knowing that Dee went
to high school or where that just simply
doesn't make sense yeah it doesn't
matter and nobody gives a [ __ ] no and if
you do [ __ ] off yeah creeps yeah and
talking to you I'm not talking to the
listeners I'm talking to the creeps the
creeps the Watchers the Watchers
they're always watching speaking of
memory do you guys have this thing so
I've noticed recently where well not I
guess not that recently but like when I
was a kid
I feel like I could ask my dad almost
anything and he would have he would know
like
I don't know maybe 80 of the time he
would he would know like he'd be like oh
you know that's interestingly enough and
then he'd go into like the history of
the thing or he would know things I was
like how do you know that stuff and then
I thought like oh when I grow up I'll I
guess I'll I'll like know all that stuff
I'll know all that stuff too you know
what I mean
um and I don't
no even a fraction of what my dad knows
um and that's partially because he's
just far more educated than me
um but I do know things that I don't
even know how I know them do you guys
have that where like
somebody like your kid will ask you
something or or like your wife will ask
you something and she's like yeah what
is that or like what does that word mean
or whatever and you just know
I'd say that's dad brain where uh you
just go I'm gonna pretend like I know no
matter what because this little
[ __ ] needs to know who's in
charge oh okay so you're saying I don't
actually know the answer to the right
questions and neither did my dad right
no that's right that's right he's just
making you feel safe and comfortable
like you got it all under control just
don't worry about it I like to think
that I'm the type of person who if I
don't know though I I will say like I I
don't know but let's look it up let's
find out I think that's what changed
right now we all have uh something in
our pocket that can we can instantly get
answers and so we we don't need to know
and maybe you're a little bit more as
much and then you just start popping out
facts right because homeboy might go
look it up might go Google it and find
out that it dad's an idiot that's right
yeah he's yeah uh but like back in the
day your dad could just tell you
whatever answer and it was better to
tell you whatever answer because a
uh you know he knew you weren't gonna
shut up shut up so he got your answer
and B he didn't want to have to drive
down to the local library and [ __ ]
dive into the Dewey Decimal System
what was that that was never a good
system [ __ ] Dewey man doing his
[ __ ] Decimal System like an idiot
there was no just how about just [ __ ]
alphabetical by category what's the
Dewey Decimal System decimal system was
developed by Thomas Dewey he was then
the uh assistant district attorney of
New York state in 1933. yeah there you
go you know good yeah you just say it
yeah yeah yeah it's not true yeah I
wasn't able to read whether or not you
meant it now Thomas well because there's
enough historical sound through me
because
but Thomas Dewey was a real person he
was like a he he was the governor of New
York at one point okay so it was
Melville Dewey it was Mel doing of
course well that's why I got them mixed
up it was Melville of course someone
named [ __ ] Melville yeah is going to
create a system to make a song
everybody and I will force them to look
through my small file Kevin and they
will be infuriated with the inefficiency
of this it's no one will understand
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
entire episodes take place with just Him
[ __ ] people hauling people up and
down there yeah it doesn't seem like you
could write a whole season based on the
elevator guy that see that seems like a
[ __ ] Acid Trip like you know Hannah
whoever Barbara Hannah Barbera well that
was two guys wasn't it no it was a woman
Hannah Barbera
yeah yeah yeah who's creating cartoons
she was actually interesting enough she
was from Helena Montana and it was at a
time when women were yes this all sounds
right yeah you just go you just go with
it right I believe Hannah Barbera was
two people yeah yeah yeah yeah and and
one of them one of them must have been
like what if there's just you know
you're at a certain point you're like
we've done everything what if there's
just like a
H I don't know a sort of marble mouth
dog
uh you know his whole thing is like he's
got got to get people from A to B
but on an elevator right so he's an
elevator operator and Barbara's like
yeah I mean we got to turn this in by
noon so yes let's go yeah let's go go
what's his name sold droopy great
hilarious well that is what a writer's
room is that's what you're doing all day
long you know when you get an elevator
and you're in a real Rush yeah and you
just can't wait for that elevator to zip
up yeah what if the guy pushing buttons
for you is even slower
that's frustrating that's frustrating
that is very frustrating it's funny and
frustration is funny
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
baby I'm excited to say that we are
hereby supported by
athletic greens look at this bag of
athletic greens right here guys if we
are gonna sell out this is not a bad
place to start because this is a product
that I have been using for quite some
time you have brought this up to me
before you know I'm glad we're getting
paid for this because I I pro at some
point would have probably talked about
it anyway and that would have been well
don't tell them that because now they
know that you would have done this for
free I would have but I won't because
now I know I could get paid for it
whereas before green for green I have a
list of some good things that it has in
here so I'm going to read it 75 high
quality vitamins minerals Whole Foods
Source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens yeah yeah it's keto friendly
paleo friendly vegan friendly dairy-free
gluten-free it's a lot of things you got
less than one gram of sugar
non-GMO and guys how does it taste it
tastes good it tastes like what I want a
green drink to taste like and it's what
green drinks most often do not taste
like hard to believe less than a gram is
sugar I care about what I put in my body
I don't know I don't know about you guys
but uh I no longer treat my yourself
like a dumpster now I do treat myself
like a dumpster but I need to cleanse my
that dumpster out sometimes with
something healthy like these athletic
greens yeah yeah something good for your
gut does it help you get full release in
the morning I didn't have a problem with
that before so I don't know if it's
forcing the issue or if it's I'll tell
you what I just drank a whole bottle of
this I'll let you know okay because I
got a long drive home okay now what I'm
looking for is a full evacuation on the
freeway no no no I want to wait until I
get home oh yeah if it forces it out
somewhere on the 405. they use that same
bottle yeah
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you gotta do is you gotta
visit athletic greens.com sunny again
that's uh athleticgreens.com Sunny now
the slash Sunny part is uh that's very
important because that's how Megan gets
paid yeah otherwise she's gonna get
kicked right out of her apartment take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
thank you athletic greens again go to
athleticgreens.com sunny sunny and get
you some
[Music]
transitioning back to the episode at
hand
um
the gang sells out I don't know if by
this point the listener or the creeps
would notice uh that we're doing ads
we're doing ads because we're selling
out we're selling out at the same time
that the gang sells yeah it seemed like
the right time to sell out yeah it seems
like there's a lot of people watching
and creeping like Megan was just
complaining about not getting paid yeah
like so much you know what I mean and
she was like oh this isn't it doesn't
grow on trees like fine we'll give you
your money something so greedy and then
we realized like I want to give her my
money so I'll give her the money of the
of the products that I enjoy yes you
know what I mean it's like let's take a
group of products that we enjoy
and we'll say give us money yeah like
that we'll see it like that
and then they will and then we'll give
it to me but isn't it just like and
we'll keep a hefty portion of it
like a mom like the guys are just having
fun the dudes are just hanging having
fun they're drinking their water and
maybe a beer every two every once in a
while hanging out and then like Mom
comes in and she's like you have to
monetize this yeah
in fact no we don't even want to hear we
don't
cut that by the way I'm sorry are you
guys seeing the samurai sword up here I
just noticed that oh yeah oh yeah yeah
we're gonna summarize swords you know
what ads pay for [ __ ] pianos
you got [ __ ] to pay for immediately all
right all right so we're doing ads now
we're selling everybody grow up
it's the way the world was it's not
about it's not all about you yeah we
can't do [ __ ] for free
I can't hear from Megan from you I mean
it's not fair Megan can't pay her rant
and [ __ ] yeah
yeah I'm gonna sleep on this I'm gonna
say mortgage you know people are trying
to you know
survive man stop complaining um what do
you guys think about the whole concert
if you do have selling out you know what
I mean like Woody
what do you think what's that bring up
for you you know what I mean have you
have you ever been accused of being of
selling out and does that bring
something up for you you know what I
mean like
sure of course uh but like yeah it's an
interesting thing right
um
I had a good I had there I tell you my
story about John Malkovich when I was uh
I was doing a movie with John and uh
I had shot a commercial over the weekend
I think it was for DirecTV okay and I
was kind of embarrassed because John is
one of the Great American actors uh and
um
a great world actors I mean he's just
one one of the best so I was a little
bit like oh man I'm I'm cheesy like uh
commercial guy and here's John and uh we
were between scenes and he you know he
was like um how was your weekend and I
was like oh well how was your weekend
yeah I was like well you know it was
good I mean I kind of it's almost all
you know did it did a commercial he goes
hmm
and I said have you ever uh done a
commercial and he goes
well I've done hundreds of them
and he goes and you don't sell your soul
you rent it
so I was like [ __ ] yeah man thank God
has he done maybe just his voice no no I
recognize that voice what has he done
he's talking look it up he's talking
commercials I actually remember him just
him selling [ __ ] Tide Pods and [ __ ]
yeah he probably I think like anything
you want to make sure it doesn't feel
like you put the laundry
into the laundry machine
I can't do I don't know
wash your clothes I don't know yeah yeah
who knows it's very unique guy but uh I
don't know it's selling out it's uh you
know part of the thing this is a
profession well I don't think anybody
out there expects us to do these kinds
of things for free I think it's I I
think it's an overused expression right
but I do think there is a uh there is a
point at which selling out you know you
could maybe accuse someone of selling
out if there was a product on here that
we're I we've already gone we've had the
conversation in private but let's just
have it in public like we're getting any
company that were that we're considering
uh chilling for right yeah and so and it
doesn't necessarily mean that we're all
going to agree every single time with
every move that a company or product
makes but if we can at least understand
that we're not like we're not putting
something out into the world that we
think is inferior and inferior products
yeah it definitely changed like it used
to be if you were a big A-list actor and
you wouldn't you wouldn't do a Hyundai
commercial you know like a car
commercial or whatever not America not
in America you would go over to Japan
Korean you know like you wouldn't be
seen and then
people just uh you know like Sam Jackson
or whatever was just like no I'm just
gonna do
commercials and movies and TV or
whatever yeah the line got blurred and
thank God because like that one percent
of actor yeah they make an elite living
you know but they basically made it okay
for everyone else to like right the the
the people who aren't making as much
money as Samuel Jackson can now go and
do it and not feel like they're selling
out or yeah or not not work again you
know right are you suggesting that
you're struggling because we've already
been we've been we've been celebrity net
worth we know what no I I I I think we
established by the way most my money
comes in and goes out to other wonderful
charitable things like taking care of
Megan thanks Charlie greedy yeah at some
point well I think if we're gonna do it
let's do it like let's have fun while we
do it and one of our one of our sponsors
uh is a company called manscaped
and they sent us some scaping tools and
Glenn
and I haven't spoken to you directly but
through Megan I heard that you would be
interested in us potentially shaving
your chest hair well I I'm open to it
yeah uh I don't know that I want to do
it today uh but maybe we just got back
from Hawaii there might be a nice base
coat there's probably never a better
time
how short are we talking about what I'd
like to do what I'd like to do is if if
it's nice and thick I'd like to carve an
S into your chest and have you just be
Superman for
for a day okay I thought that would be
cool okay yeah I don't know that it'd be
cool but uh he was the original yeah
that's true but he he wasn't hairy
no but he had that you know he had the
SMS like a really hairy butt you know
what I mean like yeah like everything
was smooth except the butt like he was
from a planet where they had like just
Harry from the waist down just like
baboon butt you know or baboon but it's
not Harry it's like an explosion of it's
like an out strange flash like a bounty
butt
it wasn't a zoo recently
it's never not upsetting to see a
monkey's butt it's like it looks painful
yeah you're like what is going on with
his butt it's all jammed up lumpy it's
like a brain on its ass like what is
happening outside of it have any of you
guys ever used a manscaping tool yeah
I've used yeah yeah Clippers when did
that start happening though because I
because because when when did it become
okay socially for men to be to to be
clipping their body hair
socially
I bring it back to Brad Pitt in Fight
Club and you think it all I think that's
where it all the rivers flow back there
I think all rivers flow you let us do
commercials he let us trim our body here
he [ __ ] kicked down doors Brad Pitt
you know I mean he was just he was so
hairless in that movie yeah that uh you
think that was impossible like that that
was definitely not natural it was well I
think that would be to a razor
is that that now we're getting into
razor territory that's a turtle shell
what's that he's smooth as a turtle
shell he's because I feel like it's
socially acceptable for men to like trim
up hair to make it shorter right like
like men don't generally get a get [ __ ]
for that from other men yeah but if you
were to take a Bic razor to your body
that's a body bodybuilder's been doing
that for years
depends on your physique right like like
if you are pretty out of shape and
you're very like arms and you've Bic
razored your chest it's gonna look weird
right like you're gonna like you know
like it's right just hairy arms yeah
yeah yeah if you are super tan and
ripped and you're all shaved up too
you're probably like we're used to
seeing that so we're like okay I guess
that's your look it's fine I don't know
yeah yeah I don't know listen I here's
the thing I'll be totally honest with
you guys I'm not in great shape right
now yeah I'm fine it's fine you know
what I mean but like I I broke my
collarbone and I stopped going to the
gym and and then I never went back
yeah yeah so so I would I would I would
I would here's what I want to feel you
here's what I want
we'll do if we're gonna do this if we're
gonna trim my body hair you'd like a
week of pregnancy at least no no no what
I was gonna say is let's do it let's do
a before and after right let's do it now
when I'm a little you know pudgy around
the middle and and let's just
and then give me I don't know eight 12
weeks to get in uh in shape again and uh
and then let's do it again okay you know
what I mean so I have the opportunity to
show people what I'm really capable of
um
okay so you're saying you're you're
eight weeks out eight to twelve weeks
out
I'll give a moment well it depends on
what we're it depends on what kind of a
standard we're trying to reach what are
you looking for what do you mean that is
the standard we've already established
got it I read an article about like age
that uh that so much of it is what you
think about your age like like the
mental side of it is such a big part of
it do you feel as though you have
limitations now with your age to get
into bribe pit Fight Club shape or do
you feel as though you could get there
the only the only thing limiting I would
say uh most people honestly is well
there's two things one is you know uh
willpower right do you have the will to
to push through the hunger to push
through the the workouts you know to to
carve out that time in your schedule but
also like resources right like if you've
got if you're rich as hell and you've
got a gym in your house and you've got
you know you can you can afford like all
the supplements in the world and you
could shoot peptides into your body and
what are peptides
peptides you don't know not enough from
peptides no but you forgot the most
important thing which is genetics well
that's true yeah you have the genetics
to actually 100 100 it starts that's
that's probably number one right and
then number two is I think time and and
uh
yeah like your your willingness to to to
go through all that because it's a lot
of work but as you age it definitely
gets harder you have oh for sure for men
you have less testosterone you your skin
looks do so you're never going to look
the same as you would in your 20 even if
you got into the same kind of shape our
Skin's all stretched out and [ __ ] I'm
getting things hacked off my body every
other week from sun damage from the
vinegar
um
I don't see it yeah you can't you can't
see it you'll see it when there's a
giant scar there yeah yeah but yeah I
mean look cool are you wearing makeup
right now why can't I see this thing on
your face what's wrong with your face
[ __ ] are you talking about I've already
had you know have you have you had
things removed from your body yeah okay
so they remove it then they biopsy it
yeah
and so this one I got a biopsy and it's
like some kind of there is nothing
because they cut it you might need to
switch dermatologists because this guy
might be making a killing off you just
being like here's a rich guy I'm just
going to keep chopping [ __ ] off him and
then yeah I'm gonna charge this guy up
wow you might drop him a bit you know
what I mean because uh I I went to a guy
uh this is years ago and got some like I
had a freckle on my back and I have a
big scar now from they cut it off in
like 12 stitches but and then I go to a
different guy now and it's like no he's
never he's barely cutting off anything
you know what I mean and I feel like the
other guy was just knife happy well
maybe the maybe the first maybe the
first one was a good doctor and this
one's killing you well no not judging by
the office the second guy's got a better
better looking office if you do wonder
how those doctors get into certain
Specialties right you go to med school
because very you know very few people
when they're you know six years old and
all the other kids are like I want to be
an astronaut I want to be a football
player and he's like I want to shave
people's you know parts of their skin
off and biopsy them Nobody Does that so
they I want to look at their moles look
at moles I want to stick my feet finger
up a guy's butt all day long yeah I
don't think nobody's dream is that when
they're a kid
talking about problems
he wants to be a doctor I didn't say
that I didn't you say though he said no
kids want to be a doctor no I didn't set
dreams of being a
proctologists
what I was about to say was was a kid
does grow up though thinking I want to
be a doctor and then eventually that
turns into I don't know you know some
and some people do just become
internists or general practitioners and
you know whatever but then you know
somewhere along the way somebody's got
to go
well I guess I'll be the black guy you
know what I mean I guess I'll check out
buttholes but like are you already into
that [ __ ] like are you going through med
school and you're like discovering that
you're like I'm kind of fascinated by
like what's inside people's butts you
know yeah I want to see the blood itself
then I want to go through the butt and
see everything I want to see the journey
from the butthole through the intestines
you know what I mean maybe you're
looking at it and saying like so many
men die of so prostate cancer so you
just seeing dollar signs no you're
thinking that you want to say
not a lot of people want to do it and I
do
[Applause]
[Music]
let's do a coffee company yeah let's get
some good coffee I love coffee I don't
want to give up coffee I don't think I
could ever not drink coffee I've tried
I've tried but why why did you try to
get off of it
um
you were having too much I was having
too much and I was starting to feel like
it was actually having the opposite
effect on me like it was making me manic
uh and and and sleepy at the same time
like not it wasn't doing the good stuff
all the good stuff was going on I wasn't
getting the endorphins I was just
getting like the anger that's true I can
confirm that yeah I can confirm because
I remember describe you in three words
and be manic sleepy and angry
yeah yeah I read a book on something
called uh neurophysical pain uh which
was like this is really interesting so
what was the book it's called the way
out I forget uh
that's not Sarno is it maybe yeah well
I've read some article with Jared Leto
and he was saying he read this book and
then he got out of like back pain I
don't have back pain oh yeah yeah he was
like he had like severe pain and [ __ ]
yeah and so I've had hip pain for a
while and so I was like I'll read that
um it was really interesting so like the
guy used the example of um
if I were a hypnotist and uh he said an
unethical hypnotist and I I hypnotized
you and I told you your arm was on fire
you'd run around the room trying to Pat
it out and then I wake you up and I'd
ask you what was it like and you would
say it was extraordinary pain and to you
in that moment the pain was really your
brain was sensing it it became real
here's another example of a guy who's on
a construction site who stepped on a
nail the nail went all the way through
his shoe and he's screaming they bring
him the hospital they like saw the shoe
off and by the time they get to his foot
they see that the Nail's gone between
the toes and not actually gone in his
his foot at all whoa but the pain was
very real right the brain
supposedly
um and so he was saying like oftentimes
with people like will injure their neck
in a car accident or something and then
the body will heal in in its course of
time but
the brain keeps it's like a mistake in
the wiring right your brain keeps
sending the alarm system and saying oh
you're in pain or anytime you start to
sense pain the fear comes up that was an
interesting books
I can tell you from experience with
absolute certainty that that is true
it's certainly for me sorry for me yeah
yeah
um I had you I mean you guys remember I
used to have horrible back pain I used
to throw my back out all the time
doesn't ever happen anymore ever at all
ever
and that was due to multiple factors but
one of them being I stopped telling
myself the story this is I think this
was I think the biggest contributing
factor to me stopping not having back
pain anymore I stopped telling myself
that I had back problems and every day I
would tell myself I have a my back is
you guys now you guys are gonna make fun
I'm with you on this it's the power it's
the power of the mind but I would tell
myself like my body is strong my body is
healthy my back is strong there's
nothing wrong with my back the power of
the mind is massive you know I think
it's something you have innately which
is like a
you know is it true and I feel like
you've said this before like you've
never had the flu
I've never I've never had the flu now
but I think that's like a genetic thing
because my dad's never had the flu my
mom's never had the flu
crazy he thought he was immune to covid
but then I gave it to him
see I think I I'm one of the people
who's immune to covid because I had
every flu I had covid one through 18. so
by the time 19 came around my buyer's
like huh oh yeah yeah that's no biggie I
had all the covets I see I think I may
so I haven't gotten covered yet either
and I don't know why I've been Expo I
know I've been exposed to it like well
you've been being tested constantly
because I'm constantly being tested I am
not I was when we were doing yeah
it's possible but like usually even the
like no I want to be that asymptomatic
like I mean it is it is possible yes
um it is possible that I had it and just
was yeah asymptomatic but so if you got
it you'd just be like sickness speed
oh precisely
oh man
I say it all the time but part of why
it's so great is that it's partially
true like pseudoscience the reason that
pseudoscience works is that they're in
peop is because like psychosomatic
phenomena are real and if you keep
telling yourself that you're sick then
you're eventually going to get something
for sure but that but then then there's
limits to that if you break your femur
your femur is [ __ ] broken but you
believe it or not but the power of the
mind you see it on every day you have to
believe that you're happy you have to
believe that you're but if you have a
brain chemical imbalance it doesn't
matter how much you believe that's why
those gratitude journals are so
effective because you're forcing
yourself to think about the things that
you're grateful for on a daily basis and
you're slowly changing your brain
chemistry to to think more in a about
appreciating the things that you do have
appreciating what you do have going for
you and not focusing so much on the
negative and that is really something I
totally totally struggle with I also
like focusing on stuff that I really
love and to that end I have to bring up
that in this episode is one of my
all-time favorite Sunny Jokes which is
the conversation about wood and wood
yeah
when Charlie mistakes the conversation
about you guys wanted to be wooed for
yeah we should get some wood yeah I was
thinking about that like that's the kind
of joke that we would have done with me
early in the show and I feel like you
guys would not be into that if it got
pitched now am I wrong I no well I I
think as I recall at the time even I was
on the fence about it but I do remember
I think it was one of those situations
for me where I was like well let's get
let's get it because you know
Charlie thinks it's funny or like these
guys think it's funny and you know let's
let's get it I wasn't like totally
against it but I do think I was actually
thinking at the time like that's so
stupid uh we've never landed on how
stupid any of us are right like like I
sort of was out out of the game it's a
moving Target being like okay I'm going
to be the dumb guy in the group and that
will be what's funny and then the
dumbness really got moved around aren't
you also reading that resume I can't
remember if you got specific or or no I
don't know I wouldn't have been reading
by that point because the season two we
pretty much locked in that joke right so
you're but you're looking at Dennis's
resume and you're saying like this all
looks pretty good that's a good same
thing yeah yeah yeah you're not reading
anything oh yeah he's just he's just
making changes yeah it's a funny scene
yeah I like that moment where you're
like can I just take a pic at that yeah
just take an understanding they're like
I love the top like the the level of the
humor in that episode is so good to me
like just like it's never we're never
quite Manic and raging and it all works
pretty good yeah it's it's it's uh it's
dialed in in a really funny way in that
episode I think I got one one more
question for you guys which is if you
had to strap on your job helmets and go
get another job what would it be you had
to leave writing TV and making podcasts
wait uh uh do you mean like outside of
entertainment yes and do we have
and you have the skills to do whatever
you oh we have the skills to actually do
the thing that we want to do yeah yeah
okay okay oh oh oh okay no we're not us
like we haven't done what we've been
doing
another path it's a
interdimensional sort of question here
right like so yeah okay
um
something feel like something in the
Sciences I don't know like I like
science stuff doctor what's that doctor
no not the science of the butt
it's in that hole Yeah
in this we we could be the best of what
we do yeah sure
well I mean I I'd be a I'd be a soccer
but I'd be a professional soccer player
yeah that'd be pretty sweet yeah that'd
be the world's best golfer I guess yeah
yeah a sports I I think I would want to
run a company that makes cars and
Rockets
yeah you'd be an inventor
he's or would you just be like this I
think it would be an industrialist
okay or would you be like the guy who
just goes out and is like the face of
the company and and just sell or are you
actually you know Elon Elon Musk is that
and also has the ability to get into the
lab and break down right that is true he
can he can kind of do both I mean he can
build rockets and super cars and think
I'd want to do that as cool as it is
yeah I feel like I've been in offices
all days does he love it is he happy uh
he hasn't calculated the happiness yet
he could probably do some charts and see
you know it's happiness isn't actually
I've broken it down and I don't know
yeah he kind of talks like that a little
bit yeah and it's uh you know I have
degrees of happiness and it's not as
useful to be happy as you would think uh
it actually the problem with happiness
is well but I feel like people at that
level uh I feel like Elon Musk and Tiger
Woods are exactly the same like I don't
think Tiger Woods seems very happy to me
in fact Elon Musk seems way happier than
Tiger Woods so there's a there's a
series Michael Jordan was at his Peak he
didn't seem happy right in fact he
wasn't happy no I think I think you
would be tormented by that degree of
Drive yeah right when you if you have
you're striving for something nothing's
ever good enough which is why you are so
good at what you do because you push
yourself to the Limit and you strive to
be the best at the thing you're doing
but uh yeah
I'm sure you just derived moments of
satisfaction from that but like overall
sort of Happiness yeah I doubt it if I
could have another job it would be
something like simpler and more
clear-cut like
like moving cinder blocks from one part
of a room to the other right you know
what I mean something that's not
subjective at all but like I would
either know if it was done or not like
because that's the hard part is being a
perfectionist and being in a job that
there is no like perfect yeah that's
hard yeah yeah if you were like a
carpenter or something like Precision
yeah you could actually see your
precision
hit its final end point and know like if
the cut is right you know you've done
what you were supposed to do I don't
know if you have that personality type
though it's never it could always be a
little bit better or a little bit
different or a little bit because that's
what the demanding thing about what we
do right there is no perfect it's very
undefinable you know what uh speaking of
gratitude
um I I have a had a very big moment of
gratitude this morning when I was
driving here because do you Glenn you
know what's two blocks away from here
from the studio
you were talking about two blocks away
from here with the man who's gotten more
mentions on this Christmas
and I was pulling I was driving by and I
drove past it and then I pulled into the
into the into the parking spot and I
came into this studio and I was very
grateful I feel like we've come a long
way yeah there was a [ __ ] apartment
along the way that was only two blocks
it took 20 years to come two blocks but
man it's on the the outside looks very
different but I have very specific
memories of being in that apartment with
you and with Chris
uh we watched the entire first season of
America's Next Top Model yeah
so we just thought it was so incredible
that she loved that show uh drank a lot
of Folgers coffee if I'm not mistaken
correct yeah you were rocking the
Folgers we yeah uh we we were on a
budget yeah
we started writing a movie together a
movie called that we were at the time
calling mind games oh sure
um
I have a specific memory of actually
being in the pool
of your apartment building because we
were like we needed a break
it was one of those weird pools that if
that anybody who's ever lived in Los
Angeles would be in the center of the
building where there's no sun so the sun
there was only like sun on the on the
pool for like a 45 minute period when
it's directly over time how long are you
there in the in the apartment one year
one year
that's it God that time goes so much
faster now because it seemed like
one year and I just remember walking all
of these streets for hours because I had
nothing to do during the day because I
worked at the restaurant at night and so
I would just walk like this through the
streets for exercise and also just so I
didn't go insane you just you're just
contemplating your dreams no I was
trying to think about like how I could
not be doing this how you could get out
of this hole yeah
how do I find yeah people who are more
talented and funny and just latch onto
them it'll hold on for dear life and I
did and I'm grateful for that mm-hmm
you know uh that's a good move that you
gotta latch on to people get to surround
yourself with people that are smarter
and better than you and that's what
you're doing or uh the drive driven you
know organized uh you gotta latch on to
somebody who'll do more driven and
organized and and organized yes driven
and organized yes yeah yeah and what we
do is we find people like you and we
just stick our hooks in and we just
slowly bleed you dry overall the shark
and the fish that's like yeah
uh what is it called Remora yeah yeah
you're the shark
uh they need each other the truck needs
it for some reason but like uh does he
clean it does he clean it yeah yeah
there's lots of those things in the sea
just like picking or like I'm one of
those birds
swim into their mouths and they clean
out their tongues like ah thanks man
it's like a guess I won't eat you or the
like the like the big the big animal
like the moose or something where they
have the birds that live oh yeah eat the
inside yeah they keep the antlers fresh
and uh yeah see but I'm not
a bird out there like polishing antlers
let me get these bugs off your antlers
yeah but see I I think I would probably
be I wouldn't be the moose or the Birds
I would be the tick that you're you
don't even know yeah you don't realize
because we benefit from the the you
don't benefit from the tick in the
relationship sure we bet benefit from
one another symbiotic relationships
that's why we put up with each other and
love each other yeah
quite grateful and uh and you know and
with the fans you know we have a
relationship with them where they're
forced to listen to our advertisements
and uh they're not forced to do anything
important or not like it
well that's sort of been the attitude of
the show although all the way through
which is like we're gonna do the thing
if you like it great if you don't [ __ ]
off that's Showbiz yeah that's Showbiz
that's life that's life man that's life
baby can't you can't please everybody
hey you just try to please a very
specific demographic of 18 to 34 year
old adults that's it everybody else can
[ __ ] off
yeah that's pretty true yeah that's
pretty true that's a real sell-outy
thing to say
[Music]